in the heart of he'll grow one of South
Africa's most densely populated
neighborhoods rooftops are slowly but
surely been transformed into farmland
this one as high above chord the street
Katherine can Boulais and thandie
Ngobeni are about to start their shift
the two women left close by and belong
to the courts a rooftop food garden
cooperative I'm just cutting the yellow
use really use that have been by my son
Katherine and Tanya no hobby gardeners
the women underwent extensive training
and now produced 170 kilograms of
spinach every week the co-operative
grows also salad herbs and cabbage for
local markets and food suppliers we all
know that you can be able to plant a on
top of their roof the things can be on
top of it especially in the in the pipes
that you can put things in the pipes
that will be growing and the water that
will be recycling going down he said
that that thing that tea I didn't think
that I can do it it was a surprise for
me the garden users hydroponic
technology the crops are grown without
soil in a special water solution which
is circulated through the different
teams to feed the seedlings it allows
the crops to mature much faster and also
means they can be grown throughout the
year every day katherine needs to check
if the water has the white ph and
nutrition level there is no water
wastage here you cannot waste any even a
drop of water with the system the water
that you put there it goes inside the
transbrake it goes inside the cams break
cannot go on the floor you cannot drop
that water
a precious saving during the countrywide
drought which is causing many farmers to
lose their harvest cities including
Johannesburg have implemented water
restrictions grain meats and vegetables
are now been important resulting in food
price hikes of ten percent in 2016 with
droughts likely to increase and come in
years Johannesburg is invested in green
in its rooftops sites it's a double a
house double eight houses within the
inner city Tony four wheel and tohko una
la peau are developing rooftop forms on
city-owned buildings across Johannesburg
here they are inspecting a possible site
which will soon be transformed into
another foot garden the city provides
the space the hydroponic infrastructure
and the necessary training apart from
saving water and providing more
affordable vegetables for local markets
urban farming is also creating jobs the
rooftop gardens is one way of really
trying to empower our people to make
sure that the out of poverty they
generate income for their families so we
are going to expand this rooftop garden
basically to use our city-owned
buildings and going forward will enter
into what we call private public
partnership where we also partner with
some of the owner of the buildings in
town to make sure that we replicate this
kind of module back at the codes of
street food garden cooperative across
town many of the women did not have an
income before they joined the rooftop
garden project as well as contributing
to a greener Johannesburg they are now
running their very own business it's not
the way to ensure premier that make us
what make us proud i think is it's good
to know that you are able to take care
of yourself you are able to work for
self you don't depend on any
he would go so far the city supports six
different rooftop common projects
Katherine and her colleagues are already
thinking of expanding and employing more
people there is no shortage of suitable
rooftops in Johannesburg